You can't win with this perfect corpse of mine
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I'm
gonna use flying
I was born into a family
that doesn't like me, and I'm not allowed to make any friends, and
today is a repulsive Ittoku magic day.
It's not decided
[music] When
I was alone I'm
a bower
I'm like this Aha I'm a
green in the universe where I don't know
what's going on Ichiminami Shijo google good
ncaa If I eat a lot I'll be more energetic and lively I can speak a
little louder
Happy birthday
wow toranoana I'm watching carefully, it's good, it's good, it's good, it's good, it's a
squirrel, and it's crazy, and it's nice to have a big squirrel
[music]
What should I do with this
chaotic monster?